it's likely that the invasion started
sometime in the mid-1980s that's when
the first reported sighting was of
lionfish just north of miami
you have an animal that once it invades
can
really increase in population numbers
very rapidly
well lionfish really are sort of the
perfect storm i think in many ways as
invasive species goes they have a lot of
characteristics which make them very
successful in the invaded range they
reproduce very early in life so they
reach maturity they grow very rapidly
they're capable of dispersing
large distances during their egg and
marvel phase which ride ocean currents
a species that has venomous spines
they don't seem to have many native
predators or predators in their invaded
range here so it's possible that because
they're so armored with the venomous
spines that they don't have a lot of
natural predators which would lead them
to basically not worry about
being eaten
in general one of the major impacts that
we're going to find from this is is
essentially the fact that they're eating
a whole variety of of our native species
for one they're removing prey that would
have been available for many of our
native fish docks like snapper and
grouper that are feeding on similar
small bodied green fishes
they're also certainly having a direct
predatory impact on many of those small
reef fishes and while we don't fish for
those species those species perform
important ecological services on the
reef
very little is known about lionfish
biology and collagen our research
program on lionfish here in northeastern
florida is trying to characterize a lot
of the life history traits of lionfish
so we're looking at things like how fast
do they grow
how many times do they reproduce how
many eggs do they produce
most of the fish that we get for our
work is actually through collaborations
with local fishermen
many of those folks are very interested
obviously in what's going on with their
ecosystem supports their livelihood and
so they're very eager to help for our
part we get to get samples from a huge
geographic area that would cost us
thousands of dollars to run our own
research program
i think the best chance we have
to to mitigate some of the impacts of
lionfish is to encourage
fishery removals whether that's through
recreational spear fishermen or whether
that's through the development of a
commercial
lionfish fishery whether that be through
traps or spear fishing or
any of these other gear types but
just get a larger fraction of these fish
out of the water
i think right now the best strategy we
have for controlling the fish is human
consumption
if we can increase the amount harvested
through a variety of ways increased
demand for this species in both seafood
markets increase demand in terms of
restaurants to get restaurants to carry
it at this point no one's talking about
eradication of course but again if you
can have enough effort and mitigate
she'd been shown a relatively small
scales that can dent the population and
you can see rebounds in
some of the native fish species
you